Las computadoras cuánticas abordan problemas que no pueden ser resueltos
por las computadoras clásicas: cosas
como encontrar los materiales adecuados para habilitar
la captura de carbono para realmente
hacerle frente al cambio climático, para desarrollar
fertilizantes más eficientes que
no dañen la tierra pero también mantengan
la cadena de suministro alimentario que necesitamos para alimentar al mundo.
También hay preguntas fundamentales sobre cómo está construido nuestro universo
y cómo se comporta la materia a nivel atómico
y subatómico que necesitamos entender.
Es la próxima frontera.
Tomemos un área de investigación que ya está en marcha:
la búsqueda de nuevas baterías.
Las baterías han transformado nuestras vidas al permitirnos llevar
computadoras y teléfonos inteligentes.
Pero queda mucho por hacer: las baterías son fundamentales
para nuestro futuro de energía limpia,
ya sea para impulsar autos eléctricos o realmente
potenciar las energías renovables.
Necesitamos una química fundamentalmente diferente
para crear las baterías
del mañana. La computación cuántica
nos permitiría ver efectivamente dentro de la batería
durante sus reacciones muy complejas para que podamos
pensar en nuevos materiales
y en la estructura de las baterías que van a ser necesarias
para impulsar la próxima generación de dispositivos.
¿Cómo llegamos ahí? Construyendo los dispositivos cuánticos más avanzados del mundo
y una plataforma de desarrollo,
y poniéndola a disposición del mundo.
Solo trabajando juntos ahora
podremos resolver los problemas a los que nos enfrentaremos
juntos en el futuro.